So you have quite a bit of experience, first of all,
starting a company yourself, but also I saw maybe you can correct me,
but you have a quite, quite a bit of knowledge of, um, just the,
in general,
the startup experience of building companies that you've interacted with people.
W is there,
is there advice that you can give to somebody to found a co-founder
who wants to launch and grow a new company and do
something big and impactful in this world?
Yes. Uh, I would say, you know, like I mentioned earlier,
but make sure the vision is something that, you know,
will get you out of bed in the morning and, and we'll get,
and that you can rally other people around you to, to achieve.
Uh,
cause I see a lot of folks that sort of cared about something or
saw a window of opportunity to do something and, you know,
startups are hard and, and more often than not just being opportunistic,
isn't going to be enough to make it through all the really crappy
things that are going to happen.
So the vision just helps you psychologically to carry through the hardships,
the you and the team.
Yeah. You and the team. Yeah, exactly.
To kind of younger people interested in getting into entrepreneurship,
I would say, you know,
stay as close to like first principles and fundamentals as you
can for as long as you can. Um,
because really understanding the problems, you know,
if it's something scientific or hardware related or, um, even if it's not,
but having a deep understanding of,
of the problem and the customers and what people care about and um,
how to move something forward is more important than taking all of the
entrepreneurship classes in undergrad. So being able to think deeply.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Well, have you been surprised about how much like pivoting is involved?
Like basically rethinking what you thought initially would be the right
direction to go or is there accusing deeply enough that, uh,
you can stick in the same direction for long enough?
So our, you know,
our guiding star hasn't changed at all. Um,
so that's been pretty consistent, but we, within that,
we flip-flop on so many things, um, all the time. And, you know,
to give you one example,
it's do you stop and build a first product that's
well suited to maybe a smaller,
less exciting segment of the market or do you stay head
down and focus on, you know,
the big swing and trying to hit it out of the park right away.
And we've flipped flop between that.
And there's not a blanket answer and there are a lot of factors, but,
um, that's a hard one. And I think one,
one other piece for the aspiring founder,
I'm spending a lot of time and effort on the culture
and people piece is so important and is always an
afterthought and something that I
haven't really seen, like the founders or,
or executives that companies purposefully carve out time and
acknowledge that, yes,
this is going to take a lot of my time and resources and then,
but you'd see them after the fact trying to repair the, you know,
bro culture or whatever else is broken at the company. Um,
and I think that it's starting to change. Um,
but just to be aware of it from the beginning.
Right.
I guess it should be part of the vision of what kind of place you want to create
or what kind of like human beings.
Yeah, exactly. Like you can't wait five,
10 years and then just slap an HR person on to trying to fix it.
Like it has to be thoughtful from the beginning.
Yeah. Um, don't get me started in HR people.
Uh, don't leave HR to HR people, but I'll just leave it at that.
You didn't say that. I said, okay. Uh, yeah,
HR is actual HR is really important as is so
culture support. Yeah.
And then I also was surprised,
like I thought you could say here will be our culture and our
values and that it was kind of distinct from who I,
and my co-founder were as people. And it's like, no, that's not how that works.
We just kind of like ooze out our behaviors.
And then the company grows around that.
So you have to do a lot of like introspection and self work to not
end up with it.
It's kind of a, it's a, it's a, it's a relationship,
but it's as opposed to a relationship with two people,
it's relationship with many people. Yeah. Yeah.
You communicate so much indirectly by who you are. You have to be. Yes.
You have to live it. Yeah. Uh,
as somebody I think about this a lot,
because generally I'm full of love and all those kinds of things.
But like I also get like really passionate.
And when I see somebody in, in the context of work,
especially when I see somebody who I know can do a much better job
and they don't do a great job,
I can lose my in a way that's like Steve jobs in.
And you have to think about exactly the right way to lose your if you're going
to, or if at all,
you have to really think through that because it sends a big signal. Uh,
you know, sometimes that's okay. Like if you do deliberately,
like if you're going to do it deliberately, if you're going to say like,
I'm going to be the kind of person that allows this and pays the cost of it,
but you can't just think it's not going to have a cost.
Yes. This was like the first thing I worked on with my leadership coach was
to how not to just snap at people when they were being
an idiot. And, um,
first I got really good at apologizing.
That was the first step because it was going to take longer.
That's brilliant.
She I've got, I'm actually a lot better at it now.
And it started with things she's like every time you walk through a doorway,
think, you know, calm and take breasts before responding.
And there are all sorts of these little things we did.
And it was mostly just changing the habit.
Yeah. Boy, it's a long road.